salman rushdie n'est pas un opposant
mais il a été désigné comme ennemi de
l'islam
salman rushdie l'auteur britannique des
versets sataniques un livre jugé
blasphématoire dans certains pays
musulmans
au point qu'en 1989 une fatwa est lancée
par l'ayatollah khomeiny le leader de
l'iran a demandé aux musulmans où qu'ils
soient dans le monde entier d'exécuter
un écrivain et c est dit
en europe les stocks du livre sont
épuisés la population s'indigne de cette
chasse à l'homme
je crois franchement que c'est de la
folie pure nous sommes dans un pays
libre
on peut dire ce que l'on veut c'est
complètement stupide salman rushdie vie
cachée à londres sous protection
en 1992 il donne la première conférence
de presse depuis la fatwa non sans
ironie il suffit que je regarde derrière
moi
d'autres ce même problème madonna a plus
de fanatiques que moi
derrière ce trait d'humour le combat
devient diplomatiques alors que la
grande bretagne a gelé ses relations
avec l'iran
l'auteur en appelle au soutien de la
communauté internationale
la seule façon dont on réglera cette
question ce sera politiquement il n'y a
pas d'autres solutions possibles si ce
n'est mon assassinat et on suppose bien
sûr que cela ne se fera pas et cela
exige une action concertée par la
communauté mondiale
la france a mis du temps à prendre
position en faveur de salman rushdie
alors qu'il est invité dans une dizaine
de pays
la situation se débloque en 1993 avec
l'invitation de jack lang ministre de la
culture
ça a changé paris chargé locaux de
droite comme de gauche les politiques
français apportent leur soutien
c'est une façon justement de protester
et de refuser cette cette condamnation
et tout l'esprit qui est à l'origine de
cette condamnation
salman rushdie continue d'écrire il a
publié sept romans depuis la fatwa
en 1996 il expliquait sa démarche du
terrain je me suis dit qu'en fait la
meilleure façon de réagir si possible
c'était d'être l'écrivain que je suis
c'est à dire d'essayer de m'exprimer
avec ma propre voie peut-être qu'on va
plus forte encore ça c'était aux autres
de voir si je les fais j'essayais de
répondre à la haine en parlant de
l'amour
en 1998 le pouvoir iranien s'est
dissocié de la fa toa avant que les
autorités religieuses ne la relance en
aujourd'hui l'auteur ne vit plus cacher
sans protection bien qu'elle lui soit
imposée pour certaines sorties
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]